it was the moment that defined this
year's Oscars when Will Smith stormed
the stage and slapped Chris Rock after
he made a joke about his wife Jada
[Music]
Smith acknowledged the incident in his
acceptance speech when he picked up an
Oscar for best actor and in the days
that followed he resigned from the
academy before apologizing in a
statement the actor said I betrayed the
trust of the Academy I am heartbroken
change takes time and I am committed to
doing the work to ensure that I never
again allow violence to overtake reason
and now for the first time he's
apologized to rock directly I will say
to you
Chris I
apologize to you my behavior was
unacceptable
and I'm here whenever you're ready to
talk there's no part of me that thinks
that's the optimal way to handle
a feeling of disrespect or or insults
Smith said he'd spent the last three
months understanding the nuances and
complexities of that moment before he
decided to speak out I actually thought
it was really good I of course it's
gonna cause a lot of media stir and
there's going to be a lot of fodder and
all that but it was emotional it was
human it was real it didn't feel like a
team of PR professionals put it together
which you know he has and he's clearly
been on a process to sort of reflect
this and understand his own decisions
that night
Smith reiterated he sorry to everyone
that was affected and that when rock is
ready to talk about that night he'll be
there Aisha zahid Sky News